Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Anthony Barnett, who's a founder of the
London based global website openDemocracy,
and has also just published Taking Control
of Humanity and America After Trump and the
Pandemic.
Anthony, really great to have you on.
Speaker 6: Very good to be with you, David.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, tell us what what's
the main premise?
What's the big change that you're looking
at now in this post?
TRUMP At least for now, and maybe getting
to post-pandemic, although not really.
And it's sort of a question mark, but at least
out of the initial stages of it, what what
is materially changed in your mind?
Yeah.
Speaker 6: Well, you're right to say post-Trump
right for now, because I found two things
really surprising about what happened when
I asked when I was watching the January 6th
event and afterwards, because when it happened,
I thought Trump is finished.
And the first shock was the way in which the
Republican Party rallied to his support.
And I think what this means is if he comes
back or if a Trump like supporter like DeSantis
comes back, it will be the closest thing to
fascism that I have ever expected in my lifetime.
What I call modern fascism won't be Nazis
and won't be expansionist, but they their
calling card is now to break the rules, to
break this sense of consent and, in effect,
implement a form of white supremacy.
This is really dangerous, not just for America,
but for all of us around the world.
So that was my first shock.
And the second one was a different kind of
surprise, which was when Biden became president,
and he thanked explicitly Bernie Sanders and
the Bernie Sanders movement, and he reached
out to progressives in a constructive fashion.
And that proved very popular in terms of my
lifetime I've lived under since the beginning.
I mean, I remember Reagan and Thatcher and
since the beginning of what you might call
the money, monetary magnetism, that that sense
that the government is the problem and the
market knows the solution to aggressively
why myself have been pushed to the margins.
There's been it's been a sense of saying,
you know, you've got to accept the market.
There was a propagation of what I call fatalism
in the book.
I don't do enough.
Trump broke fatalism.
He made voting count, empowered his followers.
And at the beginning of the Biden presidency,
there was a sense of an intelligent empowerment
taking place as a counterweight.
And I thought that that is historic.
What you doing in America?
The potential I know everybody in America
at the moment, all of them are feeling very
down that the Supreme Court decisions are
making even worse.
There's a sense of pessimism in the air.
But the thing is, Biden won with a 7 million
plurality.
Trump got the largest vote any sitting president
ever got in history, got four and a half million
more votes than Obama did.
And Obama got 69.5 million.
The largest vote.
Trump got 74 million, and then Biden got 81
million.
So we if I can put it like that, we progressives
are the majority.
We've got to get our act together.
The system is rigged against us.
And so I felt we had to address this.
And the question I asked myself is what, given
the defeat of the left, given the defeat of
progressives, given the defeat, in effect,
of the socialist argument of the trade union
movement?
Why are progressive so strong?
How come there was a 7 million majority?
What is the strength?
I can understand the weaknesses.
And then I looked at this question of what
I call the humanization.
It's feminism, Black Lives Matter, human rights
underneath ization.
All these forces against the market were growing.
And I think that from the point of view, whether
it's Putin or whether it's Trump, that's the
or Xi in China or Modi in India, that's their
threat, that they understand the threat of
real democracy in a way that the I think that
the leadership of the progressive movement
certainly leads the Biden leadership doesn't
fully understand also as well the frightened
of and we've got to get our act together.
And that's what I've been trying to explore
and that's why I'm very pleased to be on your
program.
I wanted to I think there's a bigger conversation.
Well, my conversation is needed to sort out
how we go from here.
Speaker 1: Well, it's interesting when you
talk about the olive branches extended by
Joe Biden to progressives, you know what?
I think my audience, which is mostly progressive,
did not feel as though there were really too
many olive branches.
I mean, I'll give you I'll give you my perspective.
At the time, which was, yes, I voted for Joe
Biden.
I believed that on paper, Joe Biden ran on
the most progressive platform of any Democratic
nominee.
I mean, if you look at Obama in 2012 and Hillary
in 2016 on paper for what Joe Biden was promising,
it was to the left of that to some degree.
But also there was this feeling that he his
heart really wasn't in a lot of the things
he was sort of agreeing to.
Like, for example, Joe Biden talked about
maybe some student loan forgiveness.
I didn't believe for a second that that was
really something Biden was interested in,
and he's really not done anything on it.
Cannabis decriminalization or legalization,
he's sort of paid a little bit of lip service
to it.
I didn't think he really cared about that,
and he's not really taken any action on it
other than I think about 100 people whose
records have been expunged for for cannabis
related crimes or something like that.
So I went in there with eyes wide open knowing
that this was the better option.
I voted for him.
I think he's done some good things, but at
the same time, I don't know that the majority
of my progressive audience feels as though
the olive branches were serious or that they've
been followed through on.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
Well, I think this is this is right.
But I think that so there's different things
here.
There's Biden himself.
Being himself was actually shocked by Trump's
willingness to reach out to fascists.
And I don't think Biden is a racist.
I think that's really important.
And I think that his he genuinely was pleased
to put a black woman in the Supreme Court.
I think that he does believe in integration.
He is he's a multiracial figure.
I mean, that's a very deep and a very important
issue.
And I think that he reached out with his heart
wasn't in it.
But the point was and what he stated and he
understood is that without the support of
the transformative promise of the of the Bernie
Sanders movement, he wouldn't have won.
Speaker 1: So is that, I guess progress?
Even if it was cynical, it's still.
Speaker 6: Point your view of.
From our point of view, we go to say, okay,
okay, all right, we got something going for
us here.
Of course we're not looking.
Biden is a creature of the American political
establishment.
Yeah, for over the last 40 years, he pre-dates
neoliberalism, predates the marketization.
But and there's going to be a big generational
change taking place.
So.
So, okay.
We've got some strength here.
And how do we build on this strength?
And I think one of our problems is being one
of problems in America, but this is also a
problem here in the UK is too much.
Looking at the president of the center, you
know, the right built its strength on the
in the states, it built its strength locally.
So it's building locally as well.
We've got to be able to do there are there's
a very big progressive caucus in the in the
Congress.
I made a short film called US Progressives
on a Knife Edge.
I went to Washington to investigate the argument
of my book to test it, if you like.
I talked to a representative, Jamie Raskin.
I talked to Pramila Jayapal, who's the chair
of the Congressional Progressive Caucus, and
I talked to Representative Ro Khanna, who
represents Silicon Valley from California.
And they were very interesting and articulate
and serve and reaching out.
It seemed to me these are not kind of you
know, they're seeking to gain popular support,
but there isn't a progressive gathering of
governors of the US states.
There's a weakness.
Oh, weakness isn't just, oh, well, look, Biden
isn't delivering for us.
It's we've got to think, okay, this is really
serious.
We're up against violence.
We're not just going to stop this guy and
and those forces.
We've got to build the alternative in a way
that's credible and builds on that majority.
Speaker 1: In terms of building and alliances,
you talk about the need for the progressive
left to ally with centrists to achieve substantive
progress in some senses.
And I think the question of alliances is an
interesting one.
It's also very different depending on whether
a country has a parliamentary system with
proportional representation or a system like
the United States or whatever the case may
be when it comes to or I guess even thinking
about it more broadly, if the centrists don't
really want the things the progressives want,
who's compromising and those alliances?
Speaker 6: Yeah, well, this is a very good
question.
One thing which I think is shifting is that
they are beginning to understand that without
being in alliance with progressives, the center
is going to lose.
That's a very big shift.
Up until now, whether it was under Blair or
Clinton or Bill Clinton or even Obama, they
felt they didn't need they felt they didn't
need the left.
They all they needed was corporate power and
corporate support and corporate competence.
And that would be enough.
And they could they could rely upon the acquiescence
of the population.
Trump has made voting count.
He's empowered his supporters.
And unless the the forces the Democratic forces
that are opposed to Trump, unless we empower
our supporters, we're finished.
And that empowerment, if you take the Supreme
Court decision on Roe.
Now, what is a woman's right to choose?
Me, in my view.
A woman's right to choose is their right to
life.
I think life is about choice.
I think one of the extraordinary things about
that larger feminist movement is that it empowers
all of us.
I think men included in in, in, in in greater
control over our lives.
And one of the great historic problems of
the center and the liberals that you talk
to is they just say, we'll give you a better
welfare or give you the maybe we'll give you
a student loan, maybe whatever it is, you've
got to be passive.
They rely upon our passivity.
And I think that Trump has shown that that
game is over.
So we need to build on that.
And I think that we've got to be thinking
afresh.
But my argument is not that I'm an optimist,
it's that we haven't lost yet.
And we need to think about what the forces,
the positive forces that there are.
And I think that this sense of saying, okay,
we're going to show you what Democratic empowerment
is really about.
Speaker 1: We are in the few minutes we have
left.
I want to talk a little bit about the next
2 to 4 years.
You know, in many in the media always like
to say this is the most interesting, important
and significant election of our time because
it benefits the media, because that sounds
interesting.
But I've used this example before in 2012,
in the United States, when Mitt Romney was
challenging Barack Obama's reelection, I voted
for Barack Obama.
I thought he was the better choice, but it
didn't feel like it was the most consequential
election of our time.
It was sort of like, yes, taxes on the rich
will go down a little bit if Mitt Romney wins
and he's socially conservative and I'm not.
But it didn't feel as though there was as
much riding on it.
We now have a situation where Boris Johnson
resigning in the UK, the rise of the right
wing nationalist parties in Europe.
We have now in 2022 here in the United States,
the first Trump era election where Trump is
not president nor on the ballot.
And there's this real question as to whether
his constituents will remain engaged in politics
or not and how that will relate to 2024.
I'm increasingly getting the sense that the
next election cycle or two in Europe and the
United States is actually of major consequence
in setting the direction for the next decade
or more.
Do you agree with that?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I agree with that completely.
And this is the point I was trying to make
earlier.
I think that Trump now represents a break
from traditional Republicanism and this January
the sixth demonstrated that the fact that
they're saying the election was stolen, what
does this mean?
They didn't there's not really a denial that
there was a 7 million plurality for both.
What they're really saying is the people who
are voting, we don't count as Americans what
they're saying.
It's an argument for white supremacy.
It's not put in at explicitly racist terms,
but that's what it's about.
It's about imposing minority rule.
And imposing minority rule is a kind of fascism.
It's an autocracy.
And that's what's at stake.
Now, what is the opposite of that?
And this is what's exciting, if you like,
and grim and interesting and as you say, historic,
is that we can't go back to Clintonism, we
can't go back to Obama.
Those days are over partly because of the
financial crisis.
Everybody knows that government is not the
problem.
We can't trust the market.
So so we've got a choice is beginning to face
historic choice is being forced on the United
States, either Trumpism or a multi, explicitly
multiracial democratic future.
And that means mobilizing.
And that means that without progressives,
the liberal center will lose.
Speaker 1: Do you think that at this point
what happens in the U.S. is as influential
on what happens in Europe and vice versa as
at prior times?
Has the linkage been softened or made more
explicit?
Speaker 6: Well, that's also a very interesting
question.
So American hegemony over Europe has lessened
American hegemony in the world.
America is still the strongest and most powerful
country in the world, militarily and economically.
The dollar is still supreme but is no longer
rules the world in the way it did.
That is primarily thanks to China and that's
a good thing in my view.
So in one sense, Europe is now more important
than it was.
But if America goes fascist, if America embraces
Trump or DeSantis and goes from minority rule
and allies in effect with Putin, which she
in China with the war against the European
Union, then the effects will be devastating.
So this historic turning point of this coming
cycle between now and 2024 is absolutely crucial
for all of us around the world.
The United States is still the hinge country,
and the choice you're facing is still a choice
that will affect the entire world and the
future of the planet.
Speaker 1: Uh, those are those are sizable
stakes.
That's that's for sure.
We've been speaking with Anthony Barnett,
who is just published Taking Control, Humanity
and America After Trump and the Pandemic.
Anthony, really a pleasure speaking with you
today.
Speaker 6: A pleasure.
Thank you very much, David.
Take care.